all right welcome back so next up we
have an arraignment who's going to tell
us about symmetric something squares
right thank you to the organizers for
inviting me to speak and D francophone
afternoon of the session and so today I
want to tell you about symmetric sums of
squares which is joint work with three
collaborators who are all here today so
no pressure for me
so James Sanderson my head Singh and
Rekha Thomas so let me dive right in and
let me tell you what is our goal for
today so our goal is to certify the
non-negativity of a symmetric polynomial
over the hypercube and so just in case
you fall asleep or I don't get there for
time reasons
here is a meteor key result so spoiler
alert the wrong time does not have to
depend on the number of variables of the
polynomial right so I'll first give you
a little bit of background so I'll tell
you about sums of squares module and
ideal and how usually the wrong type
there does depend on a number of
variables and then I'll specify our
setting where your polynomial is
symmetric and your over the hypercube
and I'll try to justify that it's
actually a very natural setting and then
I'll move on to our results and pretty
exactly this and if there's time I'll
tell you a little bit how all of this
relates to the work of flag algebras of
special Roseboro all right so let's go
over a little bit of background which a
lot of you know but just to make sure
we're all on the same page let's go over
what is it some of curts much loan ideal
so let's say that I want to certify the
non-negativity of a polynomial P not
globally but just over the solutions of
a system of polynomial equations so for
example I couldn't want to certify that
the polynomial 1 minus y is non-negative
whenever x squared plus y squared is
equal to 1 so I really want to show that
why is that most 1 over the unit circle
that's pretty clear from a picture but
how could you actually prove that in a
more formal way well I could want to
write 1 minus y as a sum of squares
obviously I won't succeed because 1
minus y is not greater or equal to 0 for
every point in r2 but so ok I write a
sum of squares and then I remove
something and you might say well now how
do you know that you're still greater or
equal to 0
well what I'm removing
it's something that I know is zero for
every point that I care about for every
point of the unit circle x squared plus
y squared minus one is equal to zero so
I have something that is greater equal
to zero over every point of our to minus
something that I know is zero over every
point that I care about so I have
something that is greater or equal to 0
for every point that I care about and so
that's what we'll want to do in general
I'll have some ideal eye that is
generated by some set of polynomials and
I'll look at its trail of Faraday's
which will just be the roots of the
system of polynomials so here for
example my ideal would be generated by
the polynomial x squared plus y squared
minus 1 and my real Verity will be the
roots of that so just a unit circle and
so I'll say that my polynomial is a sum
of squares module and ideal if I can
write P as a sum of squares plus
something that lives within my ideal
which I know is zero right so I'll have
something that is greater equal to zero
my sum of squares plus something that I
know is zero for every point that I care
about okay
and so if it so happens that all of my
polynomials I'm squaring have degree at
most D then I'll say that this is a
decimal squares much for an ideal it's a
very nice thing here is that modulo some
very minor conditions for for the type
of systems that I'll be interested in I
will be able to do that if I let that D
grow then I will be able to find my sum
of squares so I will need to find some
positive semi-definite matrix Q just
like this here to write my sum of
squares and I'll have to find my H and
then this will give me my sum of squares
and so I can use so many fitted
programming to find Q and a runtime is
the number of variables to the order of
the degree that you need so because of
that we often see the degree as being a
measure of complexity of the problem
right so if you have that your degree is
some small constant then you can do this
in polynomial time
if D grows with n then this is a hard
complex problem so everybody good with
sum of the squares modular an ideal
great so we don't want to do that in
general we want to do this in this
specific setting so I have a case of
said discrete hyper key
that I denote by vnk so this is just a
discrete zero one hypercube whose
coordinates are indexed by cailin and
subsets of a ground set of elements 1
through n this is a pretty natural
setting I'm more become a naturalist so
for me I can think about okay I have my
grunt set of elements or the vertices of
a graph and my K subsets are actually
two element subsets are the edges of my
graph alright so this would be this kind
of setting in focus talked this morning
when he mentioned Woolsey's system for
scheduling he had variable y IJ where YJ
was one if job I was scheduled before
dub J and zero if it wasn't so this is a
very broad system and so not only am i
over the K subsets discrete hypercube
but I'm minimizing a symmetric
polynomial over the case in this case
I've set this creat hypercube
so symmetric here I mean that it is SN
invariant so I have my symmetric group
that is acting on the ground set of
elements 1 through N and I'm really
looking at the induced section on my K
element subset right so I have the
action as being applied to the variable
X I 1 through K I get X of s I apply to
I want through as applied to I K all
right I'm really looking at the induced
action and so what we'll want to do is
well minimizing maximizing it's really
equivalent to certifying non-negativity
I'll make that clear in a second
so I want to find some of the curse
certificates and I want them to be
clever I want to use the fact that oh I
have symmetry here and I'm over 2
hypercube and so I want to use symmetry
so that I can find a runtime that is
independent of n if I just used
straightforward sum of the squares
modulo ideal like we just did in the
previous slide my runtime would depend
on n and so if my problem had a gross of
developments where the number of
elements is big or ghosts infinity that
would be problematic so I want to be
clever so the case when K is equal to 1
so when I don't really have subsets
where you have a direct action on the
was done in 2014 by Kyle Beckerman
raghavaiah and James Pfeiffer but a case
case greater equal to 2 when you
actually have subsets for us left open
because the representation theory there
is a bit different and so that's the
case that I want to focus on today so
you might say well wasn't this case
already good enough well a lot of
problems are over vertices for example
but there's a lot of problems over edges
so let me give you two very specific
problem where that fits exactly our
setting so why do we want to be able to
do this so one problem is a turn type
problem so let's say that I'm given a
fixed graph H and I want to figure out
what is the maximum edge density of a
graph on n vertices that does not
contain H as a sub graph and in
particular says this is often hard I'll
be happy if I can say something in the
case when the number of vertices goes to
infinity so the smallest instance of
that is Montes theorem where you're
forming triangles in a graph right so we
know then that a Max edge density is at
most 1/2 its obtained on by complete
bipartite graphs with parts as equal in
size as possible and then this was
generalized by two Hani forbid cliques
of size a but so you can do that really
for any graph H and so if you pass on to
hyper graphs then it becomes very hard
and so here ok our varus's R is a ground
set of elements and we're really looking
at edit variables which edges stay there
there are two subsets or if I'm in the
cuneiform hyper graph there are K
subsets of my graph set of elements and
maximizing the edge density well yeah
the edge density is something that is
invariant under a set so this is exactly
inner setting and here we see yeah I
want to do this for any and in
particular I want to do this as n goes
to infinity right so if my run time
depends on the on n this will be very
problematic
another example is Ramsey type problems
so I said that I want to color the edges
of a complete graph on n vertices with
the colors either ruby or sapphire and i
want to find the smallest number of
vertices for which i'm guaranteed a ruby
clique of size R or as the fire clique
of size
well then it would be you know two
letters that are not consecutive in the
alphabet that would be problematic so
the most famous instance of that is when
R and s are both three does the theorem
that says that if you have at least six
people in a room then you're guaranteed
to have at least three people who
mutually need to know each other or
three people who mutually don't know
each other right so here on five
vertices I was able to color my edges
with red and blue so that there was no
mother chromatic triangle but on six
vertices I might have tried you know all
of possible colorings and I would have
failed I would always get a red or blue
triangle
and so here again my variables are edge
very bold right and I could do this for
K uniform hypergraphs as well so K can
be bigger than two as well I'm really
trying to show unfeasible 'ti right so I
want to show that when I have six it's
impossible that I don't get a
monochromatic triangle so in that case
I'll really be trying to show that minus
one is really greater equal to zero
right
that's how I'll show invisibility and
minus one well yeah that is a symmetric
polynomial so I am trying to certify the
non-negativity of a symmetric polynomial
here to you might say well here and it's
pretty small right here my n is 6 that's
not so bad
right but the thing is that this grows
pretty quickly so if I look at the case
when R and s are both 4 then this
becomes 18 vertices 1 R and s is 5 we
don't know we know it's between like 41
and 49 something like that and then
after that it just keeps growing very
big so if your runtime depends on the
number of vertices that you have you'll
probably be in trouble so this is a kind
of problems that visitor setting there's
many others but hopefully now you think
it's not too arbitrary of a setting so
let's go back to the turn type problem
and let's really make everything super
explicit from now on I'll just imagine
that everything is two subsets just to
make things easier all the results that
I'll tell you about will hold for K
subsets discrete hyper cubes but let us
have VM
be intercepts indiscreet hypercube or
the coordinates are indexed by pairs of
two elements of my ground set so let's
look at the smallest instead of Turan
type problem so let's look at mantles
example so I'm trying to forbid
triangles in a graph on n vertices okay
how can i model that I want to maximize
the intensity there so I'll have edged
variables right so for every pair of
verses I enjoy I will have a variable X
IJ that is either 1 if I put an edge
between I and J and 0 if I don't
so my first set of constraints ensures
exactly that I either have an edge all
right now I cannot have half an edge
then I need to make sure that every that
all the edges are died I draw do not
form any single triangle so I look at
every triplet of vertices ijk and I need
to make sure that for any three vertices
two of them do not form an edge right so
one of the associated edge variables
should be 0 so if I take their product I
should be getting 0 ok so now my
constraints ensure that I am drawing a
triangle free graph that is very good
now I will just want to maximize the
edge density over that so I just add up
all of my edge variables this will tell
me exactly how many edges I drew and I
divide by the total number of edges
there could have been interesting and so
what I want to do is to show that this
is at most 1/2 plus some little error
that goes away as n goes to infinity
right this is what I need to do if I
want to retrieve Mantle's theorem well
that's the same thing as showing that
1/2 does that little error - my
objective function so - my edge density
is greater or equal to 0 whenever I have
a triangle free graph whenever these
equations hold ok so I'm trying to
certify non-negativity great so I can
use sums of squares module an ideal
right where my ideal will be generated
basically by the equations that I have
so I want to find some positive
semi-definite matrix Q and some degree D
so that I can write this polynomial as a
sum of squares modulo my ideal so my
ideal is generated by X square and minus
X right so this is to make sure that
every
variable is either zero one and this is
to make sure that I'm triangle free and
so here okay I have my pizza matrix q I
need I'll have some vectors V that are
vectors of basis elements of the grand
masti in my quotient ring and so I can
just take any basis and so seven
different program I should allow me to
find Q right but the problem is of
course at that
well the wrong time would be the number
of variables and choose two to the order
of the degree that I need I told you the
degree is kind of considered to be you
know representative of how hard the
problem is Mantle's theorem was proven
in 1907 the proof is one line long I
imagine I hope that D is very small
constant right but even if it's a small
constant well I want to do this for any
and for any number of vertices and in
particular I want to do this as n goes
to infinity so my run time goes to
infinity infinity and that is very
problematic we see significant
programming and some of those squares as
being a very strong technique and I'm
telling you I'm not able to retrieve
this very easy theorem from 1907 so what
are we doing wrong well what we're doing
around is that we're not using symmetry
right we're not being smart we're saying
that every single one of our variable
looks different but they're not there
they all look the same so I need to use
that so to give you a little bit of
foreshadowing this is the kind of sum of
squares proof that I want this is the
kind of certificate that I want so here
instead of having a vector of all the
monomials of degree and mostly in my
quotient string I have just a vector of
two polynomials and here a vector of one
polynomial and those polynomials
represent something was figured to
symmetry right they're not random
polynomials and then because I have
these polynomials that exploit symmetry
I get constant size matrices so instead
of having infinitely big matrices I just
have a two by two and then one by one
matrix and in those matrices my entries
are functions of n so this is a
certificate for
etienne in particular it's a certificate
as n goes to infinity so this is a kind
of certificate that I will want to
obtain and we will be always able to get
something yeah so it's a vector of like
two so my first polynomial is one the
second one which is the polynomial right
and q1 is this polynomial here so
instead of having a vector of the basis
I have some vector of polynomials so if
I show so once I get this right I know
that this is greater equal to zero this
implies that this here is greater equal
to zero actually not equal I'm being a
bit tricky here it's kind of saying that
so it's a sum of squares that is equal
to some slightly different polynomial
that implies this one alright so how
will I do that how do i exploit symmetry
how do I find such certificates
well I'll like to use representation
theory you might not like representation
theory you might love it we don't need
much so we have a big vector space right
we have my quotient ring like everything
that has degree at most the end there
it's some big vector space and so all I
really want from representation theory
is to say that I can break down this big
vector space into smaller vector spaces
that retains some information about
symmetry okay so if you're not a little
bit of representation theory you know
that I can break down my big vector
space into a unique ISO to pick the
composition and so here since my group
is a symmetric group it's going to break
down into smaller vector spaces that are
labeled that are indexed by partitions
of an ax
okay then if you know a bit more
representation theory you know that oh
those break down further into
irreducible x' but that's not the way
that I want to go I want to break down
my isotopic components
into W tell lambda so for every
partition lambda I have the shape of
that partition so here the partition
five three three one gives me a shape
with five three three and one cells in
each row and then a standard tableau for
that shape lambda is just a filling of
yourselves with the numbers from 1
through n and so that each number goes
into a different box and when I read
from left to right and from top to
bottom
I should be increasing so for any
tableau I can consider the road roof of
the tableau so any action that will fix
the rows of my tableau so I for example
the action 1 4 would be fine right
because 1 & 4 would still end up in the
same row whereas the action 1 2 would
not work I would be switching the rows
of these two elements and so the W
lambda that ID composed my eye so to
pick the component and to it's just a
subspace all my Zatopek component that
is fixed by my room so we can show that
V lambda can be decomposed into a direct
sum of the W 2 lambda for standard
tableau talento so we can call n lambda
to be the number of standard tab love
shapes lambda and M lambda the dimension
of W 2 lambda if you know representation
theory that is the multiplicity of of
your irreducible okay big message is
that you have this big vector space and
now you break it down into smaller
vector spaces that keep some information
about symmetry yeah this is your
polynomial ring and then you mutt out by
your ideal and in there you only keep
things that have the grad Mo's do you
okay so okay what did we say you know
was some discouragement lying deal okay
I have a polynomial and it is a sum of
squares of degree D model an ideal if
and only if there exists a PSD matrix Q
such that P can be written as V
transpose Q V modulo my ID also plus
some H that lives in my ideal where V is
a vector of basis elements of yeah the
elements of degree at most D in my
quotient range so that's how I would do
it normally and so in the early 2000s
Kevin got Amman and Pablo came up with
this wonderful technique to exploit
symmetry in semi definite programming so
they said instead of using any basis use
a smart basis use a basis that keeps
some information about symmetry right
sure you're looking at a symmetric
problem use a visit that says something
about symmetry so okay look at the
decomposition that you get here and find
a basis for HW tell lamda all together
they'll all these little bases will give
you a basis for your big vector space V
so okay find such a basis called a
symmetry adapted basis and then what
happens to your matrix Q is that it
becomes very structured so instead of
being like anything you know now that
your matrix Q is doubly block diagonal
so for every partition so for every I so
typically you get one big block and then
for every standard tableau with in for a
partition then you get one little block
and each of these little blocks are the
same so you really just need to keep one
little block for each of your big blocks
so that means that in total the size of
your matrix goes from being the sum of
the m lambda and lambda to just the sum
of the M lambda and you know that
there's tons of zeros it's like diagonal
that's a huge improvement and so even if
you don't know much about representation
theory these are positive integers this
is much better
great
this is great but it's not enough for
what we want right so our point for us
we really want to get rid of the
dependence on em right on the number of
variables and so here how much smaller
is the size of this SDP well M lambdas
are hard to calculate but they often
depend on N and as the number of
partitions of n certainly depends on n
ok so the total size still depends on N
and then the other problem is that I
need to find this basis for each W
lambda and there's an algorithm for that
but the complexity of this algorithm
depends on n so now our goal was really
to say okay there's this wonderful
technique but it doesn't do exactly what
we want what if we just look over to
hypercube right so here this was for all
symmetric polynomials right and you can
use any group really so what if we
specify the group to BSN and we're
looking over the hypercube can we do
better then can we get rid of dukey's
issues and so we show that we can so the
first thing that we showed is that
basically if your polynomial is
symmetric and there does exist sum of
squares of degree D then you can find a
certificate just by keeping a few
partitions in get'em anti-hero so just
keep the first few blocks and we tell
you exactly which ones to keep and then
you'll be fine you won't lose any power
or any information and so the number of
blocks that you need to keep doesn't
depend on n it just depends on the
degree D and the M lambdas for each of
them so the size of those blocks also is
in a pattern of an ax great so that's
good so for example in the proof of man
tells theorem that we saw before I kept
two blocks
I kept the blocks corresponding to the
partition m and n minus 1 one
okay that's good then there's still the
problem of we need a symmetric symmetry
adapted faces right and so the algorithm
for that depends on n well there the
idea is very simple instead of a basis
just find a spanning set so find a
spanning set for all the partitions that
you're keeping so these are the
partitions you're keeping
now of course your spanning sets are
going to be bigger than a basis so you
need to make sure that now these are not
too big that you're not losing the fact
that we just got the size of the SDP to
be independent of n so each spanning set
should have size independent of L and we
won't have to be easy to generate right
we won the runtime to generate them to
be independent of n and so we show that
such spanning sets do exist they're very
simple so for example you can just
symmetrize a monomial under the row
group and you can take an appropriate
merge transformation you get another one
for free that's good news so whenever
you are trying to certify the
non-negativity out of a polynomial over
a case of the discrete hypercube then
you know that you can do this in a
runtime that is independent of n that
only depends on D the degree that you
need in your son of squares of course
the degree can depend on n right in that
case you're screwed yeah there's nothing
that you can do but if it's a nice
tractable problem where the degree is
small then this is going to be fantastic
right both for K is equal to 1 by the
work of Gregg draw and James or a for K
greater equality to the good news don't
stop there let me in two minutes tell
you about how this links to the work of
flag algebras so husband of in the early
2000s introduced the concept of a flag
which for him is just a partially
labeled graph and so he uses this flag
to certify symmetric inequalities that
give good upper bound for many types of
problems but to keep in spirit with this
talk turn type problems and so the key
features there is that he gets some of
those squares but there's some of those
curves of Kraft densities not a felon
and because of that and this appears
right so this whole and being big and or
going to infinity business that's
problematic
the problem is appears all together but
that also doesn't mean that he can only
obtain asymptotic results and nothing
else and he can only do it for dense
graphs because there's this error of
order one over and that comes in so that
can eat up the optimal solution and so
he was very successful for hyper graphs
and so some of the best results that we
have her due to him
so once see some of the squares one can
wonder is there any link a big person
asked Sasha house will have about this
you know is there a link to traditional
solar theory and such a said no no no
and well he was wrong for once in his
life he was wrong so basically we show
that such as flags if you think about
them as polynomials they are actually
spanning sets for these WTM tons right
these rogue grove road group fixed
subspaces and so those planning sets are
also an infinitive sizing so that means
that if you have a polynomial symmetric
and a sum of squares of degree D then
it's non negativity can be established
through flags on K T vertices even in
restricted cases where you have
something about types and flags it's all
good and well we had already shown that
every flag sum of squares polynomial of
degree K D can be written as a succinct
DSOs so what this means is that flag
metas are equivalent to standard
symmetry reduction methods for finding
some of the squares over discrete
hypercube one might be a bit faster than
the other but it's going to be they're
going to be very close is really what
we're getting at and so I think I will
stop here thank you
[Applause]
but the obvious question is so what's
the dependent indeed what is what I mean
we we did calculate it at some time it's
not so bad but it's not a pretty formula
either no it's not exponential it's a
polynomial in D and so usually for the
most weres you have a certificate if you
don't have a proof right of degree D you
have some similar thing you mean like it
more complexity result type of well
let's say you want to find you have your
favorite zoom that you want to prove you
want to prove it with a sum of square
proved s SQ justice of degree D and you
try and you don't find one then it's not
possible to do it I mean we've never
tried presumably we could certainly
we're trying to get positive results so
what we do if we fail with a certain
degree then we just go higher right so
we're more in the positive result kind
of business and other people could go in
other way with it for sure
[Applause]